okay feels good great
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Callisto protocol I
am not where I remember IB right I need
to shoot then I need to reload and then
I need to grab this and then I'm going
to jump into the future so don't pay
attention or try to follow me it'll just
end in your own demise okay I'm back on
track and also I remember to grab the
fuse because I don't think I did that
last time but now I'm going to do that
and I'm going to put it right in here
and then I'm gonna go forward with the
confidence of knowing that I can kill
anybody here
this is always a good thing I mean maybe
not always a good thing but probably
sometimes a good thing I need to meet
back up with the other guy and also I
need to remember why in the hell I went
down here in the first place or why I
was sent down here on some kind of a
mission and I just wonder how I'm going
to be betrayed again I think what I'm
trying to do is reconnect with him
upstairs but for some reason the
elevator he sent me into exploded
oh this is good what am I looking at
size of that thing I was already looking
at it man what I'm in the elevator I see
the show
Elias you there
okay I guess not all right I'm on my own
again I don't even remember what the
shoe was
the shoe
lies hey buddy pal friend best friend
actually
the best friend I have oh hey you're
actually there
stay here and run a manual override
don't worry
I can get you over there I'll activate
the gondola right now they'll carry you
across
okay all right remind me what the shoe
is and how it's going to help us wasn't
that like Solitaire or something or did
I go down into solitary was that what I
went through I can't remember
all right maybe I could stay in the nice
comfy room and you could go down into
hell and do the things where you got to
go across and do that whatever you told
me to do and I've already forgotten what
it was
anywho
glad we're both not infected which is
definitely a thing that we aren't
yeah I need to sell
um again I don't know what these do
and I know that it's probably bad for me
to sell them but I'm selling them also
didn't I get
I know shut up I got a different thing
right I got the didn't I didn't I get
did I not get it I did get it did I not
get it
wait did I did I get did I did I it's
gone but did I get
I can make a health injector oh skunk
gun what is that
apparently more powerful one-handed
shotgun
oh this is so expensive
oh my God you can shut up I'll save my
money for now I don't exactly have a lot
of it where where where am I go where am
I go where am I go this way I go I'm
going
I don't think it would matter if you
actually were nice to me and didn't rush
me
maybe it would be okay this must be
solitary because those look like
solitary confinement cubes and I know a
solitary confinement Cube no one asked
how I know that thing but I know that
thing hey
uh
hey maybe not
should I shoot you guys I feel like I
should be shooting you guys
ow okay this is a problem
oh boy I should have been shooting you a
lot before
oh boy
yeah
okay
oh ow wow what in the hell happened
there
okay well I wasted literally every
single one of my bullets
but I have a good feeling that it's
gonna go to do I'm really looking at
this ground here for some reason I
really want to look at the ground here
Ah that's what was happening see I was
trying to stomp on the the guy for the
the things and uh
stuff
hey look another Health injector well
that's awfully handy I wonder how many
of those I've missed probably too many
and probably everyone's been yelling me
about it but I didn't see any of your
yelling so I'm I'm
a gerp I have a funny feeling that
that's going to be like some kind of
death trap but right now it seems to be
okay
battery pack maybe I should use another
Health injector
don't like the look of this
got a bad feeling about all this
I have two gate fuses why why do I have
two gate fuses why do I want two gate
fuses
was there a point to this it was not a
point to that was there
I was supposed to leave him in there
nope you're still locked what
oh all bees I go allpies I didn't even
notice I forgot about my Vault training
I always forget the vaulting or the
shimmying or whichever one that is
important at the moment
but I definitely need to go up there
because I see lights up there and I see
this which is a convenient path up thank
you
and I'm sure that I need these fuses
hello I'm gonna steal your neck yeah
sanitary all right what is what is you
during processing song assaulted and
hospitalized two members of the lazos
cartel advice utilizing kinetic cell
system for all shoe transfers to avoid
future incidents with inmates of this
size temperament and criminal background
all right
duly noted I'll remember that
I'll keep that in mind they sure are
trying to give me a lot of Health
so I'm gonna inject myself with
mysterious green Health goo and I'm
going to take another one of those
because I don't like how many they're
giving me and I don't have nearly enough
bullets to really handily deal with
anything here we go
Yahoo oh
oh
wait how did I grab no no how did I grab
again how do I there we go and then
launch
whoa let me hear you and you yeah
okay that is Andy I do like that
whoa
uh I can't grab you
how do I grab you whoa and I need to use
an energy thing I think oh that doesn't
sound good use
really hope there's a faster way to do
that ow
hey oh you're too big to grab aren't you
yeah that's what you get
ow why
okay that's weird why am I no block what
okay they do that and then suddenly I
know go is that what that do is that
what that do now am I dead I'm dead
lay down
how do I grab again I've forgotten how
to grab
there we go
okay weird
there we go
oh I can grab you I was just not hitting
the right button
that's like I got unlimited gerp uh
uh okay is it over
I mean gerp is yeah why haven't I been
using gerp
where are you I don't see you
come here
all right man this is awfully convenient
look at this it's a freaking Bonanza
oh oh hey oh yeah oh no grip
man that is Handy
whoa whoa whoa
oops that's not what I meant
oops that's not what I'm in either
oh
well that went well I'm not sure what
this is supposed to be in terms of like
a prison but uh really handy for that
have I always been able to do gerp and I
just wasn't gerping properly because I
feel like I feel like that wasn't nearly
as effective as it was before and I feel
like the deter well you get gerped
where'd you go
interpreter
wait wait oh good thing I can dodge you
from the ground idiot oh you're dead all
right
that's a lot of credits all right I'm
officially out of gerp it seems like my
gerp bar is actually empty this time so
I should use a gerp energy oh it auto
magically used them
[Music]
oh well that's handy and now I'm
completely out of that but that's okay I
don't care things are meant to be used I
use them effectively
and that's all that matters I'm not
gonna look back in the past and try to
be any kind of hesitant to use it in the
future I'm going to use it when I need
it period uh wait before I do that let
me go to here
ugc printing for all your needs thanks
thank you what is an energy converter
let me actually look at what this does
components that can be sold for Callisto
credits at a reforge for a low price the
ujc has authorized the purchase of this
Contraband to get it out of circulation
so it's just meant to be sold
it's just meant to be sold it doesn't
really seem like it's just meant to be
sold but it seems like it's just meant
to be sold also I can I now have 900.
I could make a skunk gun
I'm gonna hold off I'm gonna hold off oh
we'll break the assailant's arm if they
block the melee attack yes because that
seems to be what's getting me I don't
know how that works
just makes it real break your army style
but I prefer the melee weapon anyway it
seems like Melee is what they want
people to go for and I'm all about melee
just like based on all my experience
reading up 40K melee in the future is
the inevitability of everything you may
think it's guns and lasers and all this
stuff now it's melee
oh
more energy converter yay I'll go ahead
and sell that yay
all right I'm just guessing that's what
that's meant to be
all right I did the thing I think
whatever the thing I rubbed my hand all
over that
hey
all right what can take the elevator
down to the zoo
yes down
die that was quite a drop my friend it
was quite a drop there's gonna be more
enemies but I can break their arms now
though they can try to block me all they
want it ain't gonna work
oh hey pal I used to be afraid of you I
used to be used to be afraid of you and
now you're afraid of me probably please
please be afraid of me please really
please be afraid of me I really whoa hey
whoa hey whoa
yeah nice
stupid
oh yes yes God damn destroyed
devast you're alive no devastated you
want what he's having you want what he
had do you want what he had you want me
yet that's right I didn't dodge that all
right come here you come here you ow
okay
what the hell
why was that slow Moshi
oh my God oh you're on fire
get out of here
ow
oh wow
why are you still on fire I feel like
this is uh not how this should go
oh my God okay see it is getting better
and now that the block is there or the
Block Breaker is there rather
I am very very getting very happy whoa
can I still swamp you I still can't okay
good thing it was hiding that in his
Tootsie good thing in the big toe it was
hiding an entire Health injector
almost lost that all right where am I
going well I I didn't see the objective
I was too distracted by the uh the
tootsie medicine
um
fully had some kind of a way point I'm
glad I don't I'm not actually serious
about that I'm okay with using
environmental Clues to see things and
I'm seeing with my eyes that I need to
go
oh please no no no no no no no Downy no
no no no no there's a light over here
um
no
oh
Downy oh no
am I dumb oh what did do I have a goal
free the inmate what
inmate oh no I'm dumb
oh God what
what am I oh here here this one this is
the one
that was way too stressful that was
legitimately stressful for me
hello
[Music]
oh I don't like that
no he's not sure this is the right one
get me out of here what are you doing
here
this is what we're looking for yeah much
new with someone who could help us why
would I help you
well I've been here forever I've got all
the information on this place and I can
get us to the hangar right you you go
down a shower and he can fly out that we
can do this we just gotta stick together
all right it's leadership right there
listen to him I'll take my chance all
right you don't even know what's going
on out there word of advice though
he's not what he seems
I don't know how you know anything about
me
well that's a problem I had no idea
I thought you knew everything about this
place
so what now now
you need me to go to
you need me to go to hell is that
wait
I need to go to the poop place I need to
go to waste processing which wasted in
prison probably pooping dead bodies I
gotta go to poop Town there's a lot of
games that have you sent into poop town
I guess if there's one thing in the
future that's constant it's always going
to be humans are pooping
great
hello
is this elevator gonna fall to a
tumultuous demise
oh convenient
man thank goodness they still make air
ducts in the future
besides pooping people still gotta
breathe why here's something else
am I hearing someone creeping up behind
me
I do it I knew it I knew it I knew it no
you know what no block this nerd
whoa all right
take some of that and then one of these
in one of these and one of these and one
of the Stomps
I am amazing and also shimmy
I didn't like that
so what do I do about that before it
grabs my jugular
just gonna grab my jugular ah I know
what I do
well I thought that was gonna blow up it
turns out it did not blow up
I really thought that was gonna blow up
I I had full confidence in the blow up
100 confident in that blown up but it
did not
okay hey
I'm gonna have to sneak out the way you
came in
look for a vent in the fall corner
do you know I'm here do you know I'm
here do you know I'm here how do you
know I'm here how do you know
how'd you know that
what is this weird device you know I'm
not sure about the future but I don't
think that's real
I think that's one of the make em ups
hey it's a vent in the corner all right
did I hear a big Rumble never mind I'm
never going back there
I'm shimmying
too busy shimmy
steam you're gonna be spooky steam oh I
don't trust you
whoa
oh I knew it I knew it I called it
called it I don't trust any of these
buttholes but I definitely didn't trust
that one in the corner he was gonna grab
me or he was gonna spawn babies in my
face
interesting
too good
to be God no one could ever
get me
oh that doesn't look good looks like I
might I'm I'm about to be God I'm about
to be God
what is that what was that that's what I
said what was that
oh oh God okay well that was lovely okay
all right yep okay all right thank you
okay good good can you why am I known
please stop oh my God
I don't know what I just did but I hated
everything about it
no no no no God oh God
you know what I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna you know you know you
know just gonna you know
okay I didn't see that one coming
holy Jesus
uh can I stomp you
oh
thank you
thank you for participating just need to
make sure I got all the goodies my
inventory has got to be not full at all
that's strange I don't know how that is
I should be good for the next encounter
whatever it is I imagine they're just
gonna throw another tiny thing at me
nibble away at my health
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait go back go back go back go back go
back go back go back I thought that
wasn't going to be a shimmyable
which way am I oh I'm not supposed to go
that way this is the only way never mind
I thought that was a vent that I could
crawl in with
oh this refreshing boiling steam is good
on my neck also just sidebar the game is
running much much better they did a few
patches since the last time and this is
like just much much smoother so this is
now fantastic
[Music]
foreign
oh
oh no your hand
s
damn damn
I am pretty good
all right another gerpa battery that's
good definitely don't jump off into the
abyss there
uh do I gurp you do I climb did I climb
down I don't even remember where I came
from there's no other way to go
how did I get you I have no memory of
this place I didn't climb down because I
would have remembered climbing down
that's why I don't remember climbing
down it's all these shimmies
if I go wait a minute I did jump down
and I bet it needs me to grip that blue
thing because the grip on my neck is
blue and that thing had blue edges
edges oh
oh I'm really understanding my gamer
instinct is throbbing oh man this is why
they voted me gamer of the Year this
right here everybody this is it oh my
God I'm a genius ah good thing it tells
me afterwards I don't need to know until
ever
yes and then what
oh yeah
damn
face down ass up am I right anyway
sorry DNA sample test probably not gonna
go too good for me once we get out of
here it's going to Showcase that uh oh
completed that uh I ain't uh too good
I don't feel so good
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh wait wait whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa wait
a minute wait a minute I can't melee
that wait I can't I can't I don't think
I can melee that also can I turn off my
flashlight at all or am I just gonna go
dick out with all right I'm going we're
going dick out everybody we're just
wandering in the dip jail let me slam a
little bit Make some noise
a thump a challenge out to this guy
shoot the robot's head I don't want to I
don't feel like I need to
um so I'm not gonna do that
thank you
good we good we good holy [ __ ]
oh my God okay we good oh
no no no no no no no
oh my God
which way are you going
holy [ __ ] I picked the right way oh my
God okay I see yellow there
just to climb up that oh my God
oh my god oh this is not good timing my
dude it's not good timing whoa really
this is that was really aggressive
um I'm out of here uh you have fun with
the robo you have fun with the robo
I'm going for it yeah leisurely stroll
that was for the best that was for the
best oh
they think they're better at me crawling
around in vents how dare they they think
they're better than me you're not better
than me you're never gonna be better
than me
where are you one more thing
what to say what now
yeah don't repeat yourself that that's
definitely not crucial information
definitely not I'm not worried
is that part of the Trap the electricity
is this part of the Trap this looks like
it might be part of a trap this looks
very trap-like
if I had to guess
seems like a bit of a trap oh it's fine
this is definitely not the Trap this the
Trap
don't be ridiculous it's sparking for
prison reasons you know
prisons and all that
don't mind the train whistle that's
rapidly increasing not part of the Trap
definitely not trap like not trapesque
and not alluding to any kind of a trap
well that's all part of the working
machinery of what makes up prison
function that
definitely not a trap
100 not a trap
interesting they put this health here
you know but not as a trap definitely
not what you would call or trap I guess
I might as well send my inventories full
man that that train whistle just keeps
going up
all right anyway not a trap though I'm
gonna run over here okay hey bud whoa
whoa hey this is well well I don't think
that should have happened like that I
feel like I was in the protective corner
and I was dodging out of the way and I
was at no point in any danger all right
let's try this again but this time I'm
just gonna go I'm gonna go right back
where am I
well you're dead dude
all right I know I just got full health
so I don't even think I need to do any
of that I'm pretty sure I gotta go in
those alcoves
but it didn't like me going in the
Alcove before so I'm just guessing that
it's not oh hey what's up pal can you
not
can you please not
oh boy can you just stay there and die
please thank you
okay good we've tested the theory and
the theory is true
yes please thank you
hi I'm gonna make it I'm definitely
gonna make it
[Laughter]
as I always suspected I was totally fine
from the very beginning
nothing to worry about here and I didn't
Panic at all no one could say anything
otherwise
I made it I'm at the checkpoint uh
uh he's cold uh we got snow and a big
old planet
hell of you
I got eyes on the hanger too yeah
I'll take it run plenty of jobs out of
that place
it feels like a lifetime ago
how the hell am I supposed to get there
what is that supposed to mean no you
should work down there
foreign
[Music]
got like a convenience store or
something I really could use for a
shopping spree I really could use me for
that views gots that beautiful view out
there no now that I'm into the end of
the game like I really do like it I like
the combat I bet I haven't looked up
anything but I bet the combat is very
divisive I actually really enjoy it it
keeps it engaged and tense so that you
know normally when you're playing games
like this and you introduce combat into
a horror game it kind of detracts from
it but each of the encounters feels very
intense I imagine that if I was playing
this on a harder difficulty and like
mistakes were really really deadly which
even now they are it would be even more
stressful and to some people that might
be like oh damn it but I I like Elden
ring and stuff like that that's very
punishing not comparing this deldon ring
in any way but just in the mechanics of
being punishing and keeping the tension
there of like making every encounter
just being like Oh God because in Dead
Space you know a Necromorph is just like
a Necromorph they gotta make tougher
versions of them but even them are just
like you just hit them in the in the
right Limbs and you got them these it's
like it's a dance and it's like each one
could be could go very poorly if you do
the dance wrong
while recording what recording did I
need a recording here what about her I
must I missed some things every so often
with this and I have a United I don't
know what the hell they talk about
um I can sell one of these because I
have uh there's a there's a a box over
there I don't really have anything else
I can upgrade at this juncture
we'll grab this honestly I don't even
know if I need two of these but I could
get this blocking counter attack and
unlocks a new low attack
opens the enemy to follow up attacks
I'll take it all right so how do I do a
low attack
it doesn't tell me you gonna tell me
there it is okay s to block an enemy
attack I didn't know about that a
successfully blocked attack will result
in much less damage after blocking look
for an opportunity low attacks will
damage and then knock
enemy down okay so that I'm guessing
that there are certain attacks that I
need to block like the final chain in an
enemy's attack but I just haven't
encountered it yet so I don't know what
that is also wasn't I supposed to look
for a recording I don't know
Xeno recording I'm just gonna go down
into hole I'm gonna go down the hole
I like climbing down holes
especially pitch black ones it's
probably fine
it's probably fine there's probably
nothing down here
oh yeah this is fine
God damn they put a lot of
detail into these places there's goddamn
gorgeous
it's gorgees
gorgeous
it is really is undeniable undeniable
this looks like an arena
I'm looking for the death traps this
looks like from The Cinematic of uh
Starcraft 2 the one where the Marine is
getting outfitted with armor this looks
like that same room even down to the
light in the weird yellow piping
weirdly similar I don't like it I like
it I like that cinematic but I don't
like what's going on here
oh that's not good
main one that comes off and take six
goes all the way to the Dome
red pipe
you drag this way down to it
just need to follow it back I don't
wanna know what did that I can't follow
the red pie because this is broken wait
a minute
what do I do with this do all boxes have
anti-gravity
oh convenient
I'm gonna ignore the scream I'm gonna
ignore that scream that scream's not
important hey you're red pipe
that bodes well for me
[Music]
and the blood red blood perfect it's
like a Cavalcade of Blues
pipes perfect perfect for this excursion
that I am upon
oh boy poop
yay oh God
oh God
oh my God
oh my God
oh God oh God
oh
oh oh oh
God why
why hello why are you even here don't do
anything
foreign
oh my do I even want to pick anything up
all right did you get ground to bits do
you grind up my items my items oh God I
hate this so much everything was fine
everything was fine
I'm never gonna get clean is there a
shower after this one can only hope
there's a shower if I don't get the
disease of whatever turns these things
into mutants I'm gonna get literally
every other disease known to man and
some unknown that will be named after me
once I get them and die from them via
blood explosion
anyway I'm over it I'm I'm better now
what
what
oh yeah crawl right down in there you
didn't need to go that deep but you did
[Music]
what I don't wanna
I really could just be kneeling that oh
what's that
probably nothing I'm gonna push that out
of my mind and forget that it ever
occurred because that's the only way I
can protect myself and my fragile sanity
my fragile fragile sanity
gurgle croaking is
n't I'm gonna hide just in case
definitely it doesn't see me
[Music]
thank you
see any access
I'll go find a way inside
okay you do that I'm gonna go this way
[Music]
hello
uh whoops there we go just to make it
easy on myself
I'm covered in poop and I don't feel
like dealing with arduous tasks
something else gonna fight me here
I noticed the convenient Spike walls you
know the sewage spikes
yeah I don't know where are you going
shut up I don't know where I'm going I
was following you
it's the first time my own character
that I've been playing in the game has
gotten sassy with me for not going the
right direction listen I get enough of
it from you guys I don't need it from
you we're buds we're Pals we're in this
together and we're we're gonna get
through this but you gotta be you got
you gotta let me have my moments you
gotta let me have my me times
that's what I was doing before you
wouldn't know that I also know
thank you
it's now approximately
hours
of evolution is staggering organic
camouflage biophagic secretions
it's adapting to the environment
adapting
what have you done what have you done
what do you mean I don't know what
you've done
oh I don't have that one okay well
that's how horrifying I'm gonna open
this box now pretend like all this is
A-Okay which it is 100 definitely nice
oh nice oh nice yeah yeah nice nice very
nice not nice like the poop I was just
in which is still caked into my skin
it's definitely there's thick layers on
my clothes I still reek in fact I
probably worse now because that time to
bake
oh good
is someone else going to die right in
front of me
so eager for it
oh wait no if someone's not gonna die
right for me it's gonna be me I'm gonna
be the one to die
oh hi
yippee
oh
uh that's fine
oh wait a minute
wait wait a Hosey
way to who's he who's your ways of whoa
hold on a second I didn't see nothing I
saw something that wasn't a trick of the
light that was that was a something
I was 100 of something I
saw
that from a mile away
uh-huh
what are you scared
oh God
okay feels good great
okay well hold on a second you
go
Go Gadget Drop into the pit that worked
we can't believe that worked
how did that work I have no idea is that
when I shot I think I shot that one
I don't did I
take care of it
did I just
take care of it
like I did wow
turns out nope turns out dropping it
into the pit
shockingly effective I know I probably
don't need to shoot all those but it's a
just in case make me feel better kind of
thing and I'd get more ammo so it's fine
I'm looking at oh I'm looking at this
now I didn't
yeah get in there
oh oh [ __ ] oh you're fine
come here
come here
yeah do something
oh your arm's gone
okay I think I should have had that one
so there's got to be another one of
these gate things unless that door is
actually open right now which it might
be
also I don't know how that thing snuck
up on me
flickering lights maybe no
okay
I'm good I guess
away I go
poop man to the rescue so glad I never
have to dip myself in a vat of feces
ever again
need to what now the red pipe what'd you
say about the red pipe yeah I know the
red pipe
all know the red pipe what's this
hmm
okay well I do but there seems to be
some extraneous stuff over here
why does it sound so horrifyingly scary
when you do that clearly this is not the
red pipe but
could be something good
okay good I don't know where I am
was I supposed to go this way or was I
supposed to follow the red pipe because
cake cakes
that's expensive stuff
a gun costs like barely more than that
grandma
I don't know where I am oh nope
not today
oh there's more aren't they I hear them
gurgling around my head
nice
nice
oh no I'm full
wait why is my bar flashing three dots
now well seems to be okay all right
whatever
this oh wow this has got to be just like
a side area for supplies and then the
real area is has got to be somewhere
follow the river where did I come from
okay I came from here got it okay so I
just go back and follow the red pipe
that was just a supply
a supply side quest all right now down
the red pipe yippity hey
yippee so oh God the poop again oh
what
[Music]
God damn there's so many of you bulbous
gross
I know it's probably a waste of ammo but
I just want to make sure all the big
ones are definitely dead
that's a lot of supplies
thanks for the bullets so it's probably
best to do it just because they give you
enough bullets to make up for however
many you would shoot at them almost
always also are these things poop based
well so this thankfully this doesn't
look too much like poop it might be at
least somewhat water but there was
something in the water so I don't like
that no it's poop it's it's poop it's
poop I did poop
what does this do how did that guy
explode I don't know anything
oh ah
what did I do oh
can I go in the workshop I really want
to go in the workshop I don't want to go
in another crawl space
good thing this is the steam vent
you know the one they put all the steam
in
for prisoning
am I in the workshop now
I think to be in the workshop
oh
how lovely
it's a shop ujc printing for all your
needs great all of them wow I have 300
um
stability upgrade I don't really care
about the stability maybe I could get a
gerp upgrade that would be good recharge
rate it recharges Target can be injured
upon it recharges you tell me this thing
recharges
I didn't know recharges that's amazing
best news to me
I thought I would always need the group
batteries
hey pretty cool all right and with that
I am gonna put a pause as much as I know
you guys are all like oh but please
continue the poop Adventure poop
adventure's gotta pause because I gotta
vomit and then I'll be back for the next
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye-bye
[Music]
foreign